lorraine ramsey is
stranded kovid 19 means phuket in
thailand is locking down
so are you guys the only ones here yeah
for more than a week her and her partner
have been trying to get home
they've lost 7 000 pounds on cancelled
flights
they're down to their last hundred
pounds
this room is now home rising coronavirus
cases means they stay
inside during the day there are curfews
at night
i just want home you just want to get
home
this is okay for holidays no for loving
here how does it make you feel
it's just it's killing me it's going
i'm at the end of my tail and i just
don't know what to do
i just can't eat i hadn't caught anymore
police now patrolled phuket's beaches
telling people to leave
the island's sea and land borders are
closed
next week the airport will temporarily
shut down
too we managed to grab a few minutes
fresh air
the uk government's pledged 75 million
pounds to help
rescue an unprecedented number of
stranded britons
but lorraine's feeling abandoned to be a
british citizen
and not to be helped by the british
government and she's horrendous
they're not helping us they they are
putting online
or you're putting 75 million pounds to
send people home
who's that for who is that for because
it's no for us
we contacted the british embassy in
bangkok to see if they could help
it's my name nancy speaking here that
evening she receives a call back
when i phoned the first time they said
you're not a charity we're not here to
help
these two should be on a flight home
this weekend
but for many others worldwide commercial
options have run out
their only hope is government wrestling
siobhan robbins
sky news phuket